the Nairobi mole siege is now in its
fourth day with more heavy gunfire heard
earlier within the last hour the Kenyan
Army has announced that three of its
soldiers have died of their injuries
sustained in the operation meanwhile
there is confusion over those involved
in the attack last night
Kenya's Foreign Minister said that a
British woman is among the fighters but
now the Somali terror group al-shabaab
which says it's behind the attack has
said that those who have claimed
American and British people are amongst
the militants do not know what is going
on well the other main developments this
lunchtime more gunfire has been heard
coming from the shopping centre
al-shabaab claims its fighters are still
holding their ground and still have
hostages meanwhile a CCTV image has
emerged of two armed militants inside
the mall overnight there was a fire in
the center but the Kenyan government
says all hostages are now believed to
have been freed